>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> It is my honor and my pleasure
to introduce Elizabeth
Alexander this morning.
Her achievements are varied and many
as a poet, essayist, playwright,
teacher, and as a mentor.
And in particular, I want to single
out the quiet and essential role
of the mentor of the trailblazer.
She shapes the lives of tomorrow's
leaders in the classroom,
is chair of African-American Studies
at Yale University and as a poet
of course she introduced the world
to our nation's leader
President Barrack Obama
by reciting her poem Praise Song
for the Day at his inauguration.
In doing so, she became only the
fourth poet in our nation's history
to participate in the highest
ceremony marking our democracy.
The National Endowment
for the Arts is happy
to have supported the publication of
this poem and some 17 years before
that the NEA awarded Elizabeth
Alexander a creative writing
fellowship to support her
development as a poet.
It's safe to say that
that investment paid off.
From her debut collection The
Venus Hottentot to the blues
and jazz reefs of her Pulitzer
Prize finalist American Sublime,
Elizabeth Alexander has
tracked the path, the personal
and the historical inverse.
And we as a people are
richer for that journey.
I particularly recommend
her collection of new
and selected poems Crave Radiance.
And this is available at the
book signing area for purchase
and also her signing will be
from 11:30 to 12:30 this morning.
So please join me in
welcoming Elizabeth Alexander.
[ Applause ]
>> Good morning everybody.
Thank you for answering back.
That's always nice and thank
you John Piddy [phonetic]
for that lovely, lovely introduction
and for that money 17 years ago.
It really does make a difference.
And it particularly makes a
difference in the life of poets.
We do our work.
We know that we have readers.
We know that human beings whither
without poetry and without art.
But sometimes as an art form it
doesn't get a lot of attention
and so when that acknowledgment
comes it means a lot
to us in our little tribe.
Washington, D.C. is where I
grew up and so I wanna start
with a couple of Washington poems.
Summertime.
Where we live there are
caged peacocks in summertime.
Heavy in the heat, bald
headed, dragging their tails
which once a season they unfurl.
Objects wrinkle in the heat
waves rising from the pavement.
A dead rat in the back alley
gets a proper burial from a girl
who can flip her eyelids inside out.
And at the funeral, I wear my white
go-go boots and sing I gotta be me.
We buy coverless comic books cut
rate impossibly red vending machine
pistachios which stain our hands.
A hydrant illicitly opened.
Kids riding the hard spray
caught in the rainbow of water.
On television, senators
talk, talk, talk.
A Wham-O Super Ball bounces off a
sidewalk crack and into the cosmos.
A red rubber planet could
bounce to the sky and stick.
And another Washington poem and a
childhood poem, Washington Etude.
After rain mushrooms appear in
the park but you cannot eat them.
1967, the year of the locust.
They come to Northwest
Washington by millions
and for days I crunched shed husks
beneath my feet as they rattle
and hiss their rage from the trees.
Baby teeth bite, baby onion
grass and honeysuckle nipples,
tiny tongue balancing
the clear sweet drops.
I am a hummingbird.
A cat who laps cream from the bowl.
Dandelions are yellow
one day, white the next.
A mud puddle surrounded by brambles
and blackberries is where God lives.
Buttercups under my chin
tell me all I need to know.
Nothing blue occurs naturally
in Washington someone
says and I believe it.
I'm put to bed when it's still light
and hear other children
playing out my window.
Watch daylight bow.
Regard the flare of blooming
stars, the cicada's maraca.
[ Applause ]
>> And it seems apt today actually
that almost any Washington
poem I could have read
from this book references the
weather though it is not yesterday.
But, you know, we tropic
flowers are used to this.
That's what it is to
grow up in Washington,
D.C. But it's nice to see fans.
I feel we should all have
beautiful fans on a day like today.
Ars Poetica Number 100, I Believe.
Poetry, I tell my students,
is idiosyncratic.
Poetry is where we are ourselves,
(though Sterling Brown said
"Every 'I' is a dramatic 'I'")
digging in the clam flats
for the shell that snaps,
emptying the proverbial pocketbook.
Poetry is what you find in the dirt
in the corner, overhear on the bus,
God in the details, the only
way to get from here to there.
Poetry (and now my voice is
rising) is not all love, love, love,
and I'm sorry the dog died.
Poetry (here I hear myself loudest)
is the human voice, and are we not
of interest to each other?
And I thought about
that quite a bit,
have thought about that quite
a bit over the last few years.
The idea of poetry as the
human voice and that one
of the many things that poetry does
for us kind of large is give us
that distilled and precise
human voice with which to reach
across the voids that
separate human beings.
And I think that's very important.
This is another, there's a whole
series of Ars Poeticas in this book
and one of them, the one that I just
read, is sort of a classical one
in the sense of it is about
the art of writing poetry.
But then as I kept going
with them I thought what
about the art of the everyday?
What about the artfulness
with which we do small things
in our day-to-day lives.
And so a whole series of
Ars Poeticas grew from that.
And this is a poem called
Ars Poetica Number 28,
African Leave-Taking Disorder
which I have to always tell,
but good you laughed
because you know
that that's not really a disease.
And that the poem will make clear
to you what I'm talking about.
African Leave-Taking Disorder.
The talk is good.
The two friends linger at the door.
Urban crickets sing with them.
There is no after the
supper and talk.
The talk is good.
These two friends linger at
the door, half in, half out,
'til one decides to
walk the other home.
And so they walk, more talk, the
new doorstep, the nightgowned wife
who shakes her head and smiles from
the bedroom window as the men talk
in love and the crickets sing along.
The joke would be if the one now
home walked the other one home,
where they started, to
keep talking, and so on:
"African Leave-Taking Disorder,"
which names her children
everywhere trying
to come back together and talk.
[ Applause ]
>> This is a dream poem.
So enter the landscape, crash.
And I've been, this poem, I've
been thinking about in particular.
It's about a dozen years old
but I've been thinking about it
in the last couple of years with
the change of administration
and the challenges that
that brings to the populace.
Crash. I am the last woman off
of the plane that has crashed
in a cornfield near Philly,
picking through hot metal
for my rucksack and diaper bag.
No black box, no fuselage, just
sistergirl pilot wiping soot
from her eyes, happy to be alive.
Her dreadlocks will hold
the smoke for weeks.
All the white passengers
bailed out before impact,
so certain a sister
couldn't navigate the crash.
O gender. O race.
O ye of little faith.
Here we are in the cornfield,
bruised and dirty but alive.
I invite sistergirl pilot home
for dinner at my parents',
for my mother's roast chicken
with gravy and rice, to celebrate.
[ Applause ]
>> Black Poets Talk about the Dead.
"Like Toni," he said, "who came
plain as day to my dream last night
in a gangster beret,
tangerine-colored suit,
thigh-high go-go boots,
she tipped that brim
and said, how ya like me now?
After Etheridge passed I went to
see his women with my daughter
who was six at that
time and had loved him.
We slept in the room where he'd
slept and in the night my child woke
up and said I was talking
to Etheridge just now.
Can't you smell his cigarettes?
After she left us we felt mom close.
She had passed but not crossed
and those where good weeks.
Her soup in the freezer,
perfume in her handkerchiefs,
half empty cups of
her tea grown cold.
But bit by bit she
left and then was gone.
They do that so we can mourn.
They do that so we believe it.
It is what it is, wretched work.
That we who the dead
live behind must doom.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
Autumn Passage.
On suffering, which is real.
On the mouth that never closes,
the air that dries the mouth.
On the miraculous dying
body, its greens and purples.
On the beauty of hair itself.
On the dazzling toddler:
"Like eggplant," he says,
when you say "Vegetable,"
"Chrysanthemum" to "Flower."
On his grandmother's suffering,
larger than vanished skyscrapers,
September zucchini,
other things too big.
For her glory that goes along with
it, glory of grown children's vigil,
communal fealty, glory of
the body that operates even
as it falls apart, the body that
can no longer even make fever
but nonetheless burns florid and
bright and magnificent as it dims,
as it shrinks, as it
turns to something else.
[ Applause ]
>> Poised.
Having become my grandmother by
always carrying a folding umbrella
in my pocketbook, by virtue
of having reached the age she
was when I first knew her.
I always carry peanuts,
Kleenex, spare pencils.
I now understand just in case.
I am the woman who drills a finger
in a child's mid-spine for posture.
I wear red lipstick, no
longer buy cheap shoes.
I see who I have become
when my child parrots
gracious or lord have mercy.
I perched like a bird, smack dab
in the middle of a power line.
My life half coming, half done.
[ Applause ]
>> So I'm gonna read two
poems and then I would love
to have a conversation with you all.
So then we'll have some questions
and then I'll finish
with one read poem.
So this poem was written in,
after watching an Obama rally
in Miami in October of 2008.
And the poem, it starts with
that image but it is not
about that moment or about
that person, hopefully.
That was not my intent.
My intent was that it would do
meditate on something larger
than the moment but
start in the moment.
Rally Miami October 2008.
The awesome weight
of the world had not
yet descended upon his
athlete's shoulders.
I saw someone light
but not feathered jog
up to the rickety stage like a
jock off the court, played my game,
did my best and the silent
crowd listened and dreamed.
The children sat high on
their parents' shoulders.
Then the crowd made noise
that gathered and grew
until it was loud and
was loud as the sea.
What it meant or would mean was not
yet fixed nor could be though
human beings always tilt toward we.
Praise Song for the Day.
Each day we go about our
business, walking past each other,
catching each other's eyes or
not, about to speak or speaking.
All about us is noise.
All about us is noise and
bramble, thorn and din,
each one of our ancestors
on our tongues.
Someone is stitching up a hem,
darning a hole in a uniform,
patching a tire, repairing
the things in need of repair.
Someone is trying to
make music somewhere,
with a pair of wooden spoons
on an oil drum, with cello,
boom box, harmonica, voice.
A woman and her son
wait for the bus.
A farmer considers the changing sky.
A teacher says, "Take
out your pencils.
Begin." We encounter each other
in words, words spiny or smooth,
whispered or declaimed, words
to consider, reconsider.
We cross dirt roads and highways
that mark the will of someone
and then others, who said I need
to see what's on the other side.
I know there's something
better down the road.
We need to find a place
where we are safe.
We walk into that which
we cannot yet see.
Say it plain that many
have died for this day.
Sing the names of the
dead who brought us here,
who laid the train tracks, raised
the bridges, picked the cotton
and the lettuce, built brick
by brick the glittering edifices
they would then keep clean
and work inside of.
Praise song for struggle,
praise song for the day.
Praise song for every
hand-lettered sign,
the figuring-it-out
at kitchen tables.
Some live by "love thy
neighbor as thyself,"
others by "first do no harm" or
"take no more than you need."
What if the mightiest word is love?
Love beyond marital,
filial, national.
Love that casts a widening
pool of light.
Love with no need to
preempt grievance.
In today's sharp sparkle,
this winter air,
any thing can be made,
any sentence begun.
On the brink, on the
brim, on the cusp,
praise song for walking
forward in that light.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
Thank you.
I'll get those afterwards.
And so I would love
to take a few minutes
for your questions before
concluding with a short poem.
Are there any questions
about anything at all?
Yes.
[ Pause ]
>> Do you teach poetry?
>> I have taught poetry over
many, many years in the university
and also in summer workshops and
when I go give reading sometimes.
Now, in my job at Yale
University, I teach literature only.
I teach African-American literature
but I sometimes teach
in summer workshops.
>> Can ask you a second one?
>> Sure.
>> Do you think-- so is there a
basic structure of your poetry
or are you describing
a concept or an image?
I mean, is there a rhythm that
you're trying to gather or?
>> In my poems?
>> Yes.
>> Well, I hope that each
one is radically different
and utterly itself.
So I'm not a poet who comes out
of any one particular school
or any one particular form.
I like to think of the creative
process that my mind is a rolodex
and you just spin, and spin,
and spin, and spin, and spin
and have a lot of different options
for ways, directions to go in,
shapes with which to craft and sort
of enclose the material
of the poem itself.
So, no school, no doctrine,
just trying to be as wide open
as possible so that the poem
when it mysteriously comes can have
the proper craft options with which
to make it what it ought to be.
>> Thank you.
>> You're welcome.
>> There's one like yes?
>> Hi. I teach ninth and
twelfth grade English
and I introduce students
to your poetry.
They watched the video
of the inauguration
and they watched Maya Angelou's
On the Pulse of the Morning.
>> Oh, nice.
>> Ones who previously
been unenthusiastic
about poetry you could see
them get it like really.
>> Wonderful.
>> But I don't always have
inaugural events at my disposal.
And that's my question.
It's so disheartening when
I start the poetry unit
and the stereotypes
begin and they groan.
And do you have any
suggestions for the ones
who just have these preconceived
notions of how to light a fire.
>> Yeah. Did you say
seventh and eighth grades?
>> No, ninth and twelfth.
>> Ninth and twelfth.
See, here is the problem.
When they're young they don't
have those preconceived notions
and when they're young they have
an inherent attraction to pattern,
rhythm, rhyme, memorizations, song.
It's so much easier with younger
kids and then somehow this kind of,
you know, poisonous vapor gets
into the room and tells them
that poetry is hard and they won't
get and they're missing something
and they're not understanding it.
So that's what you're up against.
And my advice would be to continue
to take them back because, you know,
one of the things that I've done.
I've never been a high
school teacher
but I've done workshops
with high school kids.
And I ask them to learn and recite
something and then they say, mm, mm,
mm and I say, you know what, you
could recite 500 popular songs
or rap songs for me right now.
And then, of course they
can, every single word.
So, you know, I say let's try to
bring those two things together.
Let's think about what those
practices have in common.
And I think also there are resources
better even than recordings
of inaugural poems because
of course one of the aspects
of reciting a poem at an
inaugural is that it's a very,
very, very solemn occasion.
And so therefore I think calls
for a certain kind of
sobriety in delivery.
But there are, for
example, a wonderful series
of books called Poetry Speaks.
>> Yeah, yeah.
I know that.
>> Do you know those?
>> Yes.
>> And now there is Poetry
Speaks kind of for teenagers.
>> Oh, okay.
>> With poems that are in varying
ways thought to speak to some
of the concerns of young
people of that age.
I won't say to speak to teenage
angst but to speak to young people.
And what's beautiful about
this series, Poetry Speaks,
is that it comes with a CD of poets
reading their work and I think
that that's a terrific resource.
I think also I would put
the students themselves
because they're younger
than we are to work
on the internet finding videos
of people reading their
poetry because I'm amazed.
There is so much more than I
can find with my abilities.
And I think that that
would engage them as well.
But I think also to always remind
them that performance is one thing
and poetry does live in
the voice and in the body.
But also, part of your job is
to teach them how to
read it on the page.
>> Yes.
>> And so that's, you know, when
I'm writing a poem that's my work.
That's my work.
Reading it well is not a job
requirement but writing it well is.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah.
>> Thank you.
>> You're welcome.
[ Applause ]
>> Hi.
>> Great question and great answer.
I don't know if I could follow but
for those of us who like to write,
it'd be interesting
to know how you began,
how you plan where you're going
to end and most important,
how you edit when you're writing?
>> Well, editing is the most.
Well, I won't actually say it's the
most important part although I feel
I always must say it's
the most important part
because so often people
say, do you edit?
And I wanna say, do you
edit, what do you mean?
That's most of what I do.
That's most of what I do is pages
and pages and pages of editing
and that's how you make it
perfect and that's how you
or aspire to making it perfect.
I think for me, once again and
I hope this is useful to people
who are, you know, no poet.
It's not-- you can't
support yourself with it.
Every single poet has a full-time
day job for the most part
because you don't, you know, you
don't make much money off of it.
And so I think what that demands
is the ability to kinda walk
around with a bubble
for it in your head.
To always know that even if
you don't have, you know,
Virginia Woolf's A Room
of One's Own and even
if you don't have fresh flowers and
beautiful spring day and, you know,
peacefully slumbering children that
you can always attend to your work.
You can always keep a notebook.
You can always jot things down
and then when you are able
to find a little piece of time and
it doesn't even necessarily have
to be-- I used to think
I needed whole days
at home with nothing planned.
Well, I don't have
those days anymore.
So an hour you can
get a whole lot done.
The poet Lucille Clifton who passed
away in February who was a very,
very, very great American poet whose
work I'm sure many of you know.
She had six children and she said
a natural state for writing poetry
for me is at the kitchen table.
And she said two kids are fighting.
One has the measles, dinner
is burning and in the midst
of all that I can listen for.
And I think also part
of her point is that all
of that is the stuff
of the poems as well.
So I think of poems as something
that we attend to by going
through whatever our normal
days are alert and alive
and with our ears open and
keeping track of things and then
when we have a little quiet time
and we don't need a whole lot of it.
You just keep on plugging away,
plugging away, plugging away.
And that, since we are at
time, the poem I wanna conclude
with was written right
after Lucille Clifton died.
And one of the amazing, amazing
things that she taught so many of us
as poets and as human beings is
that worlds could be expressed
in very, very, very small spaces.
Her work was exquisitely condensed.
It also understood that
none of us stands alone
at this particular point
on the historical line.
We come from people and we
move forward into other people.
But we're connected with the
people who came before us
and were connected with the
people who come after us.
And so I got from her a
wonderful sense of continuity
and of ancestral wisdom that
is accessible if you let it be.
So this poem to end and
also just thank you so many
of you for coming for poetry.
It's a wonderful and
heartening thing to see.
And I'm really, really
happy to have been here.
And this poem is called One
Week Later in the Strange.
One week later in the strange
exhilaration after Lucille's death.
Our eyes were bright as
we received instructions.
Lined up with all we
were supposed to do.
Now seers, now grace notes, now
anchors, now tellers, now keepers
and spreaders, now wide open arms.
The cold wind of generational
shift blew all
around us stinging our cheeks,
awakening us to the open spaces
now everywhere surrounding.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you, thank you, thanks.
>> Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.